in this video we're going to talk about
some terminology that we use to talk
about
how circuits are put together
in previous videos we've talked about
the components or elements that are used
to make up circuits so for example
resistor
capacitor
and inductor
are circuit components we also call
those elements
in addition we have some sources
like a voltage source or for example a
current source those would be the
components
or elements of a circuit
lm mints
now we're going to start assembling
these things into circuits and we need a
few more words to talk about here's some
circuit components that are laying out
on the tabletop and
we're going to connect those up with a
wire so for example i could connect
this one
to this one with this yellow ideal wire
and an ideal wire has zero resistance
and it's perfect everywhere and
this forms a junction
between these two components
and that is called a
node
node is the word for junction meaning
the same thing
that's what it
that's what a note is if i connect up
these two other
components i still have one node because
i have one junction
that's the same voltage everywhere so
that's what a node is
we're going to go over to this circuit
here and we'll identify the nodes this
is a little more normal looking
tidy circuit here's a junction right
here
between
a resistor
and this voltage source so that's one
node
if i move over here i see
resistors connected together by ideal
wires so that forms one single node
like that so that's our second node
and down below same sort of thing i see
an ideal wire connecting
the resistors and the source so i can
color that in
and that's
node number three
so this circuit has three nodes
now what's connecting the nodes the
thing that's connecting the nodes is
called a branch
and a branch is the same thing as an
element
we'll count the uh
the branches or elements in this thing
this voltage source connects the third
node
to the first node so that's
one element this resistor connects node
one and node two
so that's the second
branch
this resistor connects node two and node
three so there's the third branch
and this resistor with a separate
current
also connects those two nodes so that's
the fourth branch
so
this
this circuit has one two three four
elements in it and it also means it has
four
branches four branches
so that's what a branch and a node are
i'm gonna move the picture over a little
bit so that we can do this again
on
a little more fancy circuit so first
thing we're gonna do again just to
repeat the process we're going to count
the nodes here's a junction between
a resistor
and a source
here's three resistors connected by a
perfect wire
so that's the second node
here we find
three more resistors
connected by a perfect wire there's
third
down here we have
there's a junction between two resistors
so that's our fourth node
and finally we have
this node here
connecting these four elements
with one
node
this is sometimes called a distributed
a distributed node when it's all spread
out on the page like that but it's still
just one node
so this circuit has five nodes
and if we count up the elements that
tell us how many branches there are one
element two
three
four
five
six
seven
seven elements
all right there's our two two keywords
elements
and nodes
now i'm going to quickly move
again down
bring in another circuit here
and we're going to talk about
the idea of a mesh
and the other thing we're going to talk
about is the word loop
the word mesh comes from
screen doors or screens that you put on
on your windows to keep the bugs out if
i draw a screen
like this this is what it it looks like
a bunch of crossing wires and this
little space right here that little gap
is called a mesh that's what that word
comes from
so we're going to find the meshes of our
circuit and what we look for here's the
branches
and the mesh
is a is a it is a kind of a loop that
fills up
this open space this circuit has one
mesh
two
mesh three
meshes
that's how that looks to draw a mesh you
start on a node you go through elements
until you come back to where you started
that's how we did those three and they
fill the open windows of the circuit
so this circuit has three meshes
now that a mesh is a loop
and we can have other kinds of loops too
they don't have to be just the ones that
fill the fill the windows so in general
this circuit has other loops and we'll
identify some of those we start let's
just start at one of these nodes here
and go around like that
and this is a loop
and i can draw other loops in here we'll
make them all different colors
there's a loop if i start
right here i can draw a loop
through these elements
and finally if i have a sharp eye
there's one more loop in this circuit
if i start let's just start right here
and it actually goes all the way around
the outside
so that's this circuit has three
actually if i add them together this has
three loops
that i drew here plus the three loops
that were the messers so this circuit
has six
loops
circuits always have a lot of loops and
so
usually we don't talk about these more
often it's more organized and
straightforward to talk about how many
meshes are in a circuit
all right
so that does it for this video we got
mesh and loop we talked about components
and elements
and we finished up with the idea
also of
nodes
and branches
so that'll do it there's our new
vocabulary for talking about circuits